my previous clip reveals mark norman's  favorite joke editing technique and here  it is in action i met a girl in a bar  the other day went back to her place i  take out a condom she goes where'd you  get that thing i was like well i got him  at the tire shop  free rubbers the first version is a  silly wordplay joke but it gets better  i always say the wrong thing i met a  girl once went back to her place i take  out a condom she goes whoa where'd you  get that thing i was like well they were  free at the bar  she was  so both jokes use the phrase i met a  girl at a bar and went back to her place  but the big difference he sets up the  premise i always say the wrong thing now  the punchline is him saying the wrong  thing comedy magic